hallo mein name ist nun herzlich
willkommen meine damen und herren hier
heute zu einem video über ein spiel was
mir so häufig in die kommentare
geschrieben wurde so viele leute meint
es mir hey lucadou muss dieses spiel
spielen plug and play
das ist ein stecker und das ist eine
steckdose würde so unfassbar viele leute
meinten zu mir hey lucadou muss dieses
spiel spielen
wir haben hier so einen komischen
stecker und müssen den wohl hier
reinstecken plug n play okay warum sind
hierzu finger ich kann mich bewegen soll
die sich berühren bad im moment nein
berührt wer bist du denn das ist für den
kopf
ach das ist ein stecker kopf ne muss mit
ihr okay wenn ich drauf drücken dann
dreht er die richtung ihr werdet euch
jetzt wahrscheinlich genauso wie ich
fragen was ist das für eine scheiße ich
habe ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine
ahnung
er läuft jetzt in die richtung auf jeden
fall wir haben hier dicker du bist okay
er steht wieder auf
ja mach doch was also wirklich kein
scheiß ich weiß nicht was hier machen
soll genau laufen wir wieder nach vorne
läuft wieder in die richtung das heißt
wenn ich drauf zurückgedreht er wieder
sich um jetzt soll er mal in die
richtung laufen
jetzt kommt er von der seite
eine zweite person ich weiß überhaupt
nicht was hier gerade abgeht läuft jetzt
auch in die richtung das heißt wenn ich
wieder auf dich drauf drücken dann
drehst du dich wahrscheinlich auch
wieder um genau ist drückt nochmal drauf
trick sich wiederum kann ich nach oben
gehen
du kannst nur wieder zur seite nach
unten geht auch nicht so sollte man auch
nach hier laufen
bauer männerhand ich bin jetzt quasi
wieder beim start sofern ich das richtig
beurteilen kann also steckt den ich bin
zudem stecke eine steckdose zu stecken
in der tat die strecke den stecker
wieder in die steckdose rein und auch
nie wir sind doch nicht beim staat ist
was anderes hier ist ein knopf den
drücke ich mal die person ist im hellen
und stellt sich in die reihe
ok ja dann würde ich sagen stupst mit
denen mal anja duschszene 17 an
[Musik]
nein was macht ihr solltet ihr weiter
anstupsen was ist wenn ich jetzt auf
denen hier mal drauf trikot capes er den
an der stupste was ist das für eine
scheiße ich weiß wirklich nicht warum
mir das so unfassbar häufig zu gesendet
wurde
denen kann ich ok ich muss euch beide
glaube ich so ein bisschen drüber ziehen
jetzt bin ich irgendwie wieder in diesem
fenster hier also stupst mal ruhig
weiter an genau du den und du bist tot
ich weiß nicht was die mission hier ist
auch okay jetzt jetzt
sorry falls ihr dieses video gerade
leicht verwirrend findet mir geht es da
ähnlich ich drücke mal wieder hier auf
den knopf drauf
die hier sind alle schon um geschmissen
worden der jetzt auch der auf- und jetzt
nur noch eine person ihr übrig der geht
weg und wir haben wieder einen knopf
drücke ich drauf jetzt noch jahres hält
durch wieder drauf als dunkel hell
dunkel hält doro mein gott schmeißt dann
ja immer so ein stecker da rein ich bin
sehr schreckhaft bei sowas aber gut wir
haben jetzt hier auf jeden fall so ein
kabel kann nicht da geht nicht okay ich
da wieder drauf geht auch nicht kann ich
den hier einen ballon er geht auch nicht
was soll ich hier machen es passiert
wirklich absolut gar nichts bin ich
einfach nur bescheuert oder behält also
dieser knopf hier der bimmelt irgendwie
das nicht war das nicht wahr
ich habe mich die ganze zeit gefragt
warum der ab und zu mal so wibbelt ich
kann ihn anscheinend einfach rausziehen
dann schmeiße ich den hier weg und dann
kann ich den hier da reinstecken 890
weiter geht's mit dem nächsten rätsel
hier erscheinen also ich denke das ding
mal hier rein
okay was möchtest du mit sagen jetzt
hier
okay dann sag ich dich hier rein
so und jetzt sagst du mir deinen po
hallo muss soll ich dich irgendwie ordne
mich war das doch du scheißt mit bach du
scheiße doch jetzt nicht hin offen
meinen boden noch mal ja kommt
[Musik]
ist gar kein problem du isst wie dafür
gemacht hier der boden überhaupt nicht
clean oder so was soll ich deine scheiße
jetzt hier nehmen oder das stecke ich
dir jetzt da oben wieder rein oder was
ist jetzt seine mission damit gehe ich
das hier jetzt hab ich weggeschmissen
jetzt bin ich wieder hier ich weiß nicht
was hier die mission von diesem spiel
ist was ich irgendwie machen soll ich
stecke jetzt mal den hier eindrücke ich
mal drauf okay jetzt stecke ich den mal
raus jetzt richtig hier auch wieder rein
und ich hier weiter geht's die beiden
sind jetzt hier zusammen hat unterhalten
sich hey hallo bei ok was antwortet ich
sag mal hallo hallo okay er antwortet
die rechte person antwortete du ein no
go oder do you know me ich würde einfach
mal sagen du ein know you
darauf antwortet die rechte person also
ich weiß es nicht
jetzt.de you know me also kennst du mich
oder ich kenne dich ich sage jetzt mal
einfach ich kenne dich einfach mal so
ein bisschen hier raus labern er meint
er weiß das ganze sage ich ja ich liebe
dich oder nähe kann gar nicht sein dass
du mich kennst ich würde sagen wir
fallen direkt mit der tür ins haus und
sagen ein love you
da sagt der rechte don't think i love
you go das warenkorb are you sure oder
love you ich sag mal wieder direkt ein
love you think you don't love me sagt er
love you sage ich mal am nagel
okay das ist ganz schwierig jetzt hier
gerade eine unterhaltung zwischen dem
und dem ja das ist das ist ein super
video gerade luca hörst du mir zu oder
sage ich wieder dass ich ihn liebe
ich sage einfach hörst du mir überhaupt
zu darauf antwortet der rechte als er
hört mir zu er sage ich juli nord
er hört nicht zu er sagt jetzt anhört
ich bin wieder in der dunkelheit allein
es gibt wohl nur einen richtigen weg wie
man diese konversation beendet
[Musik]
klasse lukas hat wieder super geklappt
also wirklich jetzt ist wieder alles
schwarz hier haben wir jetzt irgendwie
so ein stecker den man hier wohl
reinstedt jetzt muss ich euch hier
wieder ja dann läuft auch euro
ich klicke jetzt mal den linken hier an
und jetzt ok aber was macht er denn
jetzt kommt eine dritte person
anscheinend dazu was ist das erlaubt
jetzt nicht wirklich zudem noch mal hin
[Musik]
heuer kommt da kommt der vierte stecker
kommt kommt dj bin ich zu blöd stecker
rein zu stecken sagt was ist dass ich
habe diese beiden jetzt mal
entschlüsselt und packe den jetzt mal in
diesen hier vorne rein also so und dann
kommt der hier rein verändert das jetzt
was online
jetzt kommen wieder die finger ja mach
doch was das spiel ich denn hier für
einen schwachsinn gemacht jetzt haben
jetzt nicht wieder etwas falsch gemacht
okay er geht jetzt stecken wir den
finger
hier in die steckdose drücken auf den
schalter
jetzt ist er dort wird der finger in der
steckdose zwei spieler aus der finger
hängt so das war's
und ja das war mit abstand das komisches
spiel was ich je gespielt habe wenn euch
das video hier gefallen hat dann würde
ich mich sehr sehr sehr sehr dabei einen
daumen hoch unter diesem video hier von
euch freuen also wenn ihr einfach den
like -button drücken würde das zeigt mir
hat dieses spiel gefallen was mir so
viele leute wirklich aus gründen die ich
nicht verstehen die kommentare
geschrieben haben ich verstehe nicht was
mir dieses spiel jetzt sagen sollte ich
weiß nicht warum ich das gespielt habe
ich weiß nicht ob ich dafür geld
ausgegeben habe was ist der sinn dieses
spiels schreibt es mir gern mal unten in
die kommentare
ich bin echt leicht verstört
dr
[Musik]